our problem tells us that when 1.125
grams of a liquid hydrocarbon
cxhy so we don't know how many c's and
h's they are so it's a mystery liquid
hydrocarbon was burned in an apparatus
like that shown in figure four seven
this is the apparatus this is our
mystery hydrocarbon getting burned or
it's combusting with oxygen you need
oxygen for the combustion to occur
so when it burns in this apparatus and
it burns with oxygen
it tells us and we have 1.125 of it to
start with
it tells us that
3.447 grams of carbon dioxide and
1.647 grams of water were produced
so let me
write that reaction right there so let
me just write this first sentence right
here
write all of the information that
they're giving us
that they're giving us in that first
sentence they're saying that when we
start off with that liquid hydrocarbon
that has xcs and yh's in it
and it's in its liquid state
it's a liquid hydrocarbon
and when we combust it
using oxygen
using oxygen in its gaseous state
we will produce carbon dioxide
we will produce carbon dioxide
and
carbon dioxide and
water and you can't even really
realistically balance this equation
because you don't know how many carbons
and hydrogens you have on the left-hand
side but what they do tell us is how
many grams of everything of at least
this we start with and how many of the
grams of each of these we end up with
and we're assuming that we have an
excess of oxygen that this hydrocarbon
is the limiting reactant
limiting
reactant we just have an abundance of
oxygen just enough oxygen to burn to
turn all of this hydrocarbon to combust
all of it into carbon dioxide and water
and they tell us that we have 1.125
grams of the mystery substance and then
it produces
3.447 grams of carbon dioxide and 1.647
grams
of
of water
now to solve this well let me finish
reading the problem they tell us in a
separate reaction or in a separate
experiment the molar mass of the
compound was found to be 86.2
grams per mole so i'll write that down
here so c
x h y
molar
mass
is equal to
let me write it this way instead just to
go the convention that i've been doing
we have
86
86.2
grams of
our mystery substance
c x h y
per mole
of our mystery substance c x h y and
then they're asking us in this problem
they say determine the empirical
and molecular formulas for the unknown
hydrocarbon cxhy
and just as a refresher empirical means
just the simplest whole number ratio of
the of the atoms in our molecule so the
simplest ratio of our carbons to
hydrogens or hydrogens to carbons will
give us the empirical formula the
molecular formula is how many carbons
exactly how many carbons and hydrogens
do we have in each atom and i suspect
we're going to be able to use this
information to come up once we have the
empirical formulation the empirical
formula we then can use this molar mass
right here to figure out the actual
molecular formula but let's figure out
the empirical formula first
and the way we can do it
is we can say well gee how many moles of
carbon dioxide we get produced how many
moles of hydrogen and then we say well
in the final product how many moles of
carbon do we have then and how many
moles of hydrogen then we do we have
there and then we can figure out the
ratio and the ratio of carbons to
hydrogens or hydrogens to carbons in the
product that's going to have to be the
same as the ratio in the reactants and
they all came from this reactant right
there they didn't come from the water
and then hopefully we'll be able to
figure out what kind of the simplest
whole number ratio of hydrogens to
carbons or carbons to hydrogen is that
sounds very complicated i think but i
think if we take it step by step it
won't be
too bad
so a good place to start let's figure
out how many moles of each of these
substances we have i'll start off with
the carbon dioxide
so if i start off with the carbon
dioxide what is the molar mass of carbon
dioxide so it's atomic it's atomic
weight
carbon is 12
plus you have two oxygen so two times
the atomic weight of oxygen is 16. you
could look that up if you like but
that's equal to 44 atomic mass units
that's its atomic weight which is you
know the weighted average of all of the
isotopes and all of that business
but if you have a whole mole of carbon
dioxide 6.022 times 10 to the 23rd of
these molecules then you're going to
have 44 grams of the substance so we
have 44
grams of co2
per
mole
per mole of co 2. and if we want to
figure out how many moles we have
you know with us we know that we're
starting off with we know we're starting
off with 3.447
grams of co2
and we want to multiply this by
something that has grams of co2 in the
denominator so we want to multiply it by
something that looks like this that
looks like and we want to turn into
moles of co2 so it should have
moles of co2 over
grams of co2 well that's the complete
that's the inverse of this right here
this is grams per mole we want moles per
gram so if instead of 44 grams per mole
we have one over 44 moles per gram or
for every 44 grams we have one mole for
every one mole we have 44 grams i just
inverted this
so let's multiply
let's multiply the grams of co2 cancel
out with the grams of co2 and you are
left with
3.447
divided by 44
so let me let's figure out what that is
let's figure out what that is so you
have 3.447
divided by
44. which is equal to
zero point
zero seven eight
three four so seven eight three four let
me remember that so that is zero point
zero seven eight three four
moles of co2 that's our only units left
moles
of
co2
now let's figure out how many moles of
water we have so i can do the exact same
thing over let's see where should i do
that let me
let me write it over here so let's do
the water in orange right here
so we're starting off with
1.647
grams of h2o and what's waters what is
water's molar mass same argument its
atomic mass is you each hydrogen is one
but you have two of them so it's two
times one plus 16 which is the atomic
weight of oxygen so 2 times 1 plus 16 is
18 that's also its molar mass you could
say 18
18
grams of h2o
per mole
of h2o
now to convert this the amount of grams
we have two moles what we want to do is
multiply it by something that has
that has
moles in the numerator and grams in the
denominator we want
grams of h2o in the denominator and
moles of h2o
in the numerator and that's the exact
inverse of this so if we have 18 grams
per mole we have 1 over 18
moles per gram and what is this going to
be equal to
what is this going to be equal to so
this
cancels out with that so we're left with
1.647
divided by 18 moles of h2o let me scroll
over a little bit
and get the calculator out
clear it out and so we have 1.647
divided by 18
which is 0.0915
so let me do this in a new color
we have 0.0915
moles
of h2o so so far we figured out in our
in our products how many moles of carbon
dioxide we have
and how many moles of
water
now
i said we want to figure out the ratio
of hydrogens to carbons or carbons to
hydrogens to figure out the empirical
formula right here and to do that we can
say hey look all of the carbons
and the hydrogens in our products they
all had to come from our mystery
hydrocarbon so if we can figure out the
ratio of hydrogens to carbons in our
products we'll know the ratio of
hydrogens to carbons in our reactants
because they all have to come from this
guy right here the oxygen obviously had
no hydrogens and carbons in it so all of
these hydrogen carbons came from our
mystery substance
so how many moles of carbon do we have
how many moles of carbon do we have in
the carbon dioxide and in our products
well the only product with carbon
dioxide the only product with carbon is
the carbon dioxide this has no carbon in
it so if we have this many carbon
dioxides we also have
we also have
the same number of carbon atoms
the same number
of carbon atoms moles of
atomic carbon and you might say hey wait
what mole is that that's just a number
this is saying
.07 times you know 6.022 times 10 to the
23rd times that huge number a mole is
just a number very important to remember
so this means we have the same number of
carbons and if we have that many
waters how many hydrogens do we have
well for every
for every water molecule we have two
hydrogens so we're gonna have twice as
many hydrogen atoms so let's multiply
that times two
so times two is equal to
0.183
0.183 so we have
zero
number zero point one eight three i
could even put up trailing zero if we
because we actually had well i think i
lost a significant digit here i could
have put a
zero right there but anyway i don't
worry too much about that
0.183
moles
moles of atomic hydrogen because for
every water molecule we have two
hydrogen so i just took this number and
multiplied by two and now let's figure
out the ratio of hydrogens to carbons
and that's pretty easy
we just take the ratio of that to that
so the ratio of hydrogens to carbons is
0.183
moles
of hydrogen in our product
for every
0.07834
moles of carbon in our product and
somehow we have to make this into
some type of a whole number ratio let's
see what kind of whether we can do
anything here let's just divide this
right here and see what we get
so if we just take well we have the .183
there so let's divide it
by .07834
and you get 2.33
2.33
oh
2.336 so this is
this is approximately equal to i'll do a
new color
is approximately equal to 2.336
moles of hydrogen
for every
for every one mole
of carbon and this doesn't look like
that neat of a ratio but this is pretty
close to one-third so let's maybe if we
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by one-third by three what
do we get
well three times two is six and three
times one third is another one so this
will be seven
seven moles
of hydrogen i'm approximating it i'm
trying to get to some reasonable whole
number
seven
moles of hydrogen for every
for every three
moles of carbon and this was a little
bit of an articulate i said okay 2.33 to
1 or 2.336 to 1. well gee it just looks
like
over here this part of it looks like if
we multiply that by 3 we're going to get
pretty close to a whole number so let me
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 3. that's kind of the art
there to recognize what you have to
multiply this to turn it into a whole
number and if you don't believe me we
could take that number and multiply it
by three
and you get something very very very
very close to seven so that's that's
enough for me so you're multiplying both
by three you get seven moles of hydrogen
for every three moles of carbon and
we've figured out our empirical formula
we have
seven hydrogens for every three carbons
right if we have seven moles for every
three moles that means we have seven
hydrogens for every three carbons and so
the empirical formula of our mystery
hydrocarbon
so empirical
formula
is
for every three carbons
we have
we have seven
hydrogens
now the next thing we want to figure out
is the exact molecular form the exact
number of this is just the minimum ratio
but maybe we have you know nine carbons
for every 21 hydrogens we don't know so
let's use the other information they
gave us in the problem where they told
us that the molar mass
the molar mass is 86.2
grams per mole this this information
right here
this information right here let me copy
that
86.2 that looks like an 80 but we'll
remember it says 86.2
so let me paste it
over
over here that's what they gave us in
the problem so just for kicks just for
kicks what would be the molar mass if
this was the molecular formula so as
it's written as it's written right now
well there's a couple of ways we could
do it algebraically and all of that but
the simplest way is to say as it's
written right now what would be the what
would be the molecular mass of this well
it would be or the molar mass i should
say so it would be 3 times 12 3 times 12
plus 7
times 1. 3 times 12 is 36 plus 7 is
equal to 43.
so the if this was the molecular formula
its molecular mass would be 43 grams per
mole but they tell us in the problem
they tell us in the problem that the
molecular mass is 86
grams per mole so they are saying that
the mass is twice as much of this we
must have twice as many atoms in the
same ratio so the molecular
the molecular formula for this
we're in the home stretch now the
molecular
the molecular
formula
must have twice as many atoms in the
exact same ratios so it must be
c3
h7 times two or we could write that as
c
6
c 6
h
14. so we have this is still a ratio of
7 of 14 to 6 which is 7 to 3 but using
this information we were able to figure
out the exact number of carbons and the
exact number of hydrogens in
this
molecule anyway hopefully you found that
fun